[Applause]
i did watch a reunion okay oh yeah can i
tell you one thing
they ain't like hermione b
i don't think hermione uh uh
harry and ron got on emma watson yeah i
don't think they got along that well
towards the end towards the end there
was that one moment where like i think
ron was trying to have like a beautiful
tv moment oh yeah he's like i love you
and she was like she would not say that
she wasn't saying i shouldn't and he
said he doubled down
she he had i mean not romantically he
even had to like take it back awkward
son she made it awkward yeah but i have
a feeling that like and this is not her
fault because they're like young kids
going into this and like she's a young
kid who convinced herself she was
hermione and then became hermione
right like as a child she was a huge fan
did you watch them no i didn't i didn't
finish it and that's something that's
really interesting about this specific
uh book is that like all these kids not
all of them a lot of them were super
fans of the books yeah
before they could form their own
identities so they're forming their own
identities around the characters in
these books think about that and then
they become them for the next 10 years
of their lives yes and like ron even
pointed out he was the most self-aware
the most interesting that's why he quit
acting dude he's the best i dude i feel
like the ice cream truck now no
yeah he's done he's done with the
business i made my money i'm good i got
[ __ ] you money
i gotta [ __ ] you ice cream
truck he got to change his look though
yeah no he looks like he owns an ice
cream truck
he looks exactly like the character he's
like yeah he wants it yeah he still
wants to be noticed his look though i
think he don't truly care
the harry potter kid he don't look
nothing like he yeah because he's trying
to be an actor he's trying to be he's
trying to separate himself at all times
from this thing i think he's like yo i
did this thing it was dope as [ __ ] and
now i don't need to do anymore i did
what i need to do he treated acting like
childhood basketball like you get into
it when you're like 10. and then when
you're 16 you're like i don't really
want to do this and you have to do two
more movies he's like [ __ ] me out of
here but the thing was interesting is
that hermione threatening to leave
like
again this is me just i'm totally
assuming this she could be the sweetest
person in the whole world but remember
she was getting like activist-y and all
that kind of stuff as well do you
remember watching university did you
know like yale yeah they made a big deal
about her going to an ivy league she
even made a point about it in the
reunion yeah where she's like all like
these three women that were in it like
they just became amazing women and
activists yeah she made a point to point
out who became good activists yeah
which is like hermione in the book mad
annoying with that [ __ ] yeah so what i
was watching i was like it is possible
that this girl
developed
such a big ego and sense of
self-importance because of the magnitude
of the character like anybody i think
would any child put in that position
yeah i think would like the fact that
harry potter is remotely humble like the
guy who plays him daniel radcliffe like
he seemed so anxious and nervous yeah
like well if you think about the
character the character is if they
become the character his whole
character's the humble kid like i don't
want any of this but that [ __ ]
is cocky that [ __ ] thinks he
could take on everything like harry
potter is that dude right like i'll save
the world right right
[ __ ] need to learn how to hold
his breath
right it's like every movie is like you
underwater fam like what's up like when
you watch them all in a row it's all
drowning yeah have the gills like the
gills why'd he gill it up every time
yeah what did what did he use to get the
gills god damn it
i know that trivia
gillyweed yeah
we know and you should read the books
there's a lot of details
anyway i could see her like getting this
sense of like self-importance but also
not being attached to the cast
it seemed like uh ron and harry were a
little bit more bonded which in their
young kids around the same age young
boys maybe just being guys exactly yeah
yeah
i go go miles i have a different theory
i think that at the point where she was
like oh i want to get out of here is
right when she's coming into the age of
like sexualization and the guys aren't
getting sexualized like she was at that
age and there was like mad crazy stuff
about hermione there's all these crazy
things going on about her like being 16
17 in these movies and that's when she's
like
oh fame was fun as a kid and now i'm
coming into it and the guys aren't
getting what i'm getting they're getting
like all that
they're getting like they get to be
handsome and now i'm getting weird dms
and like just a bunch of rapists coming
after me i'm 16. she was getting like
stalked and [ __ ] she had like mad
restraining orders and she even had like
an 18th birthday countdown clock on a
website she had a security detail when
she turned like 15.
and the guys were able to just like sort
of be dudes and they got to be like what
a piece of [ __ ] i am for making yeah
i only thought that because she wouldn't
say i love you back to rhonda he was
saying it as a friend and i was like
this is the cruelest thing ever because
you know the whole world is going to
watch this yeah and all they want is to
see these two people in real life say i
love you to one another but maybe she
got a boyfriend who's like jealous or
something yeah
she said i love you snipe or nice night
uh alan alford oh malfoy yeah i thought
she said she was in love with him no no
no no they were like oh i love you i
love you but not romantically yeah she's
like i love him we have like a bond he
was dope too
malfoy yeah i think emma watson has like
some issues with men in her life and it
makes sense because she got like [ __ ]
over by the internet you know what i
mean
like all the activist [ __ ] i'm assuming
he's coming out of being like sexually
objectified when she's starting ah i
think that's a great point also yeah
great objectification is bad yeah
objectification is bad dude you cannot
objectify these women yeah you can't
objectify children that's yeah children
but when they're adults grown-ass women
make up for it make up for it make up
for what you didn't give them as kids
yeah let the [ __ ] let the ball go i
let you be a kid now you finna be an
adult yes
no i i think that makes a lot of sense
yeah you would want to stand up for
women if you experience the worst
type of behavior and the worst types of
experience yeah like a guy that would do
that i mean i guess it's you don't know
them so it's all fun and games to a
bunch of dudes they just have this joke
but like that's a girl yo that's a 16
year old girl yeah you don't think about
that but like yeah i'm sure that [ __ ]
um yeah i'm sure that worked for you i
almost think that's the worst type of
hot to be is like nerdy hot because you
get the worst dudes because you get like
the weirdest dudes that are into like
nerdy hot girls i think those guys are
creepier than just like
what
what
you playing
who's in the comments bro who's in the
comments a bunch of [ __ ] akash is
going crazy give me your number i love
you
no we would propose marriage like
gentlemen yeah
that's the indian hey gentlemen dawg 100
yeah
yeah she's in england in london they got
a we had no countdown clock we married
that [ __ ] at age
um miles what the [ __ ] are you opening
up over there this is like a coloring
book page
are you about to start drawing during
the podcast
every pot i just doodle so that i pay
attention and i'm not staring at you
guys because it gets you guys off of the
pods oh
i didn't know i thought it was a map of
something and i was like did you get a
piece of [ __ ] again wow guys trying to
concentrate dudes [ __ ] jobs
i know
but i thought it was an actual like map
of something and i was like does he have
a game with another game of thrones
harry potter i thought you had like a
diagon alley map or something like this
what's the map called
the diagon alley map no the one that you
can see that people walk around oh a map
of a conservatorship
the countdown clock man
no what is it the broader's map the
broader's map
hey dude hey dude hey dude hey dude
why do you have to pronounce diagon
alley exactly
it's because
because diagonally
no if you say diagonally it takes you to
another spot do you remember when that
happened to harry potter the first time
they took the dust and they went into
the fireplace at the weasley's house and
then they
he ended up in diagonally not diagon
alley what store did it end up on
in
i'm so nerdy i've done this [ __ ]
burgers
and what else is in there
the
vanishing uh the case which is how the
death eaters get into [ __ ]
hogwarts yep
y'all y'all not even fans you're not
even a fan bro
you're not a fan yeah yeah yeah i'm not
a fan that map is miles's restraining
order from emma watson
yo is emma watson your number one that's
a milestone as a kid yeah yeah
or not
i just was like because i grew up the
same age i was like i'm harry potter and
then he got to be harry potter and i was
like i'm not harry potter anymore i was
like i'll be draco like i was willing to
be anyone to like fantasize be in those
books yeah i was such a nerd oh if i
read those books as kids oh my god dude
there's it's like the [ __ ] coolest
thing in the world when you're an adult
it's like oh this is this is cool it's
fun to read when you're a kid you're
like i wish this was real i bet like i
would love to be this
i can't imagine dude thank god
if i rather [ __ ] as a kid i'd be such a
[ __ ] loser
what
what y'all waiting for me to say some
[ __ ] you're laughing deviously i was
gonna say some devious [ __ ] but then i
felt like he really cared about what he
just said and i didn't want to undercut
it all right but don't tell me what were
you gonna say just off mike i was gonna
say probably some uh homosexual slurs
okay
that would have been fun yeah that would
have been well timed yeah it would have
been well-timed
okay so can we get to this [ __ ] jon
stewart situation because this is a big
deal
so jon stewart
basically joked around that harry
potter's uh creator and writer jk
rowling must be anti-semitic because
she uh made the goblins at gringotts
bank uh all the negative stereotypes of
jews all the negative stereotypes of
juice uh except the the money one yeah
that's about all the positive
stereotypes yeah it's positive super
positive like control i mean they are
honest bankers they're not stealing
people's money yeah
like i don't i think there's only a
couple stereotypes that are bad here
that's true
uh they're honest bankers very secure
system yeah right they've got clericans
locked up like they're dragging up
taking care of their community like
what is the negative thing knows it
knows in stature and it's like dude john
why are you putting so much value in
physical looks dude like
they're not really they're not really
friendly say what they're not really
that friend oh yeah you can't you're at
work your work
this is a job you can't trust him in a
deal why not harry made a deal with that
guy and then he [ __ ]
left him took the sword and left him
that is a good ass point i remember
reading it and being like all right
you're right john stewart and then when
you [ __ ] him over the end i was like
okay yeah yeah yeah it's been like juice
yeah
so she he made a joke about this he
didn't actually think he was just joking
on the pod joking on the podcast week
comes along and then what happens and
they run a whole story jon stewart
claims harry potter's anti-semitic and
blah blah blah cancel culture whatever
it gets picked up everyone's talking
about how jon stewart's trying to cancel
harry potter and then jon stewart goes
on another show i think like this
morning right and he just goes yo it was
a joke i was riffing with my friends on
a podcast yeah he brought it up we
talked about harry potter for a few
minutes newsweek go [ __ ] yourself yes
this is a common um he said newsweek
your business model is arson
like all you guys do is profit off
destruction and try to ruin everything
yeah and then he said what's worse is i
used to respect you you used to mean
something
what happened yeah and he said you used
to be my go-to when the newsstand was
out of time yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it's um
it's a great headline
jon stewart calls out jk rowling yeah
100 i mean i'm sure that these you know
uh news week or whatever it is all these
magazines all these blogs are looking at
their data and they're like wait when jk
rowling says something anti-trans it
gets a lot of clicks this hbo thing just
came out people are really into this hbo
show they're they're upset that she
wasn't there let's see if we can tie
into the interest in this hbo review of
harry potter tap into jon stewart and
make her look even more hateful since
harry potter's creator of being hateful
is already doing well yeah
everyone loves jon stewart they know
he's jewish and he's the person to call
you out like if john stewart calls you
out it must be a real [ __ ] yeah yeah
but you also have to understand jon
stewart is a comedian yes yeah and he's
going to be hyperbolic and comedians we
do it all the time on this [ __ ]
podcast we just make a statement and try
to prove it something ridiculous all
right guys we're gonna take a break from
this exclusive patreon episode you can
get the full episode at patreon.com
flagrant2 because i gotta tell you all
about lucy look we're all adults here
and i know some of us choose to use
nicotine to relax focus or just unwind
after a long day and lucy is a modern
oral nicotine company that makes
nicotine gum lozenges and pouches for
adults who are looking for the best most
responsible way to consume their
nicotine it's a new year why not start
it out by switching to a nicotine
product that you can feel good about
this is a no-brainer something you must
do and if you're going to do it you got
to do it with lucy look after yourself
you have the opportunity so whoever it
is that's gonna switch to a better
nicotine alternative make sure they're
using lucy and you can get all the
products at
lucy.co okay go to lucy.co use the promo
code flagrant you're gonna get 20 off
all products on your first order
including the gum or the lozenges that's
lucy.co use the promo code flagrant at
checkout now i gotta read this okay
warning this product contains nicotine
nicotine is an addictive chemical but
remember if you're interested in the
better way to use nicotine visit lucy.co
and be sure to use that promo code
flagrant for 20 off your first order now
let's get back to this exclusive patreon
but i think we've had that gringotts
convo on the pod before yeah yeah i
think we did i think it's a common combo
he had it a month ago
so i feel like newsweek saw it they knew
the reunion was coming out like they
plotted yeah
you know it's interesting it's like i
think uh
if you're jewish like do you think there
are people that aren't jewish that own
banks
because maybe if you're scottish
you're not even thinking jews
run the banks because there aren't jews
in scotland running the banks ah so
you're not even putting the stereotype
together so it might be something as a
jewish dude the way you see the world
informs the world you're seeing
right you might have seen bankers as
people she doesn't trust yeah so she and
how can i make it i didn't even know
banks were the the stereotype or fact i
don't know jews run banks but i was like
i don't like these banks
who's just saying yeah who likes a bank
they give you money you gotta give them
more money yeah the overdraft fees all
this other dumb [ __ ] minimum about
they're just finding ways to take your
baby they tell you how much of your
money you're allowed to take out your
business
of race if you own a bank you're a
criminal yes stealing money left and
right yeah it just so happens the jews
occupy the most hated professions that's
not their fault
it's not their fault is it bankers
lawyers the rest of them
oh there it is no but i guess i guess
what i'm saying in all seriousness like
sometimes your own insecurities your own
stereotypes of like your world inform
what you see right maybe
living i think she's scottish right
jacob allen or she was living in
edinburgh when she was doing it i think
so maybe she just had no attachment to
that there like i don't think there's
tons of jews in scotland no one of the
banks is probably just scottish people
every time she goes in the bank and
they're like and she's like these
[ __ ] scottish douche bags holding all
the [ __ ] money like [ __ ] goblins
yeah and then starts to describe what a
goblin is
right yeah i think that can happen right
no or what of course she also was
homeless and poor at the time
newsweek's article flagrant 2 podcast
how do you think how they handle jk
rowling i hated it and i turned it off
for that reason really i thought it was
so scummy dude oh what do you mean so
either put her in or don't put her in
the reunion she turned it off after five
minutes yeah
like nine three thirty and then i was
like i'm talking about that everyone
talking and then for for jk rowling they
play a 2019 interview that she did yeah
for like a press tour or something yeah
then use that footage and then
retroactively put it in to talk have her
in it or don't have her in it i wish i
never do
wait what i wish i never knew they used
the old footage but you would have been
like why does this look mad shitty like
the lighting is 2019 in
like the background's not there the
lighting is [ __ ] it's like it looks
like it's shot poorly yeah but there's
so much uh footage from back in the day
that it didn't really seem like that big
a deal like yes she wasn't in the castle
and [ __ ] with the rest of them that
would have been really cool to see her
interacting with the characters that she
created like yes that would have been
fun for us yes and i think it's [ __ ] of
hbo to not have her in it but also i
don't know if maybe she didn't want to
be in it like if this is coming from hbo
and hbo is going you know what we're not
going to put her in because she has this
trans controversy and that's just going
to bring a negative you know a stigma to
this show and everything involved and we
don't want that so you've been canceled
from your own project that's [ __ ]
information my understanding is that's
why they put 2019 up there because
that's before the controversy
so like hey guys before any of this
happened we didn't know this old footage
and then everybody say i'm german but my
family came here before nineteen
fourteen yeah exactly and then
everything people who are watching who
are like oh she's anti-trans i don't
like her are like well this was before
so you get to feel good about you get to
watch her [ __ ] you have her in or don't
guilt-free and to be honest i'm not
interested in christopher columbus great
director he did home alone did these two
movies i don't really care what you have
to say yeah you took this book series
that was a global phenomenon and then oh
your only job is don't [ __ ] this up
i gotta give you a push-up i gotta give
you push back there man i think he's
good no no i gotta really care what he
has to say relative relative to what she
has to say okay there you go i would
like to hear from her but if if great
sure but if we're specifically talking
about the films and this is the reason
why you need a director like
the director makes a film it don't
matter how great the acting is like the
acting and all that kind of stuff is
sprinkle on top the director makes the
[ __ ] film and a lot of times the
director is the one telling those actors
what he needs from them because he's
seeing the whole film throughout and
these actors they might not even know
some of these actors myself included
just show up with the [ __ ] size for
that day they don't know how that scene
relates to anything else yeah him in
particular with kids i get why he's good
but also like and i'm sorry to interrupt
you but like
what i was fascinated by the most it was
like this daunting task like who is
doing all the [ __ ] cgi who's doing
all the effects is the director hiring
someone who just specializes in that and
then he just goes i don't have to think
about this at all or is that also his
vision how somebody operates how
somebody uh does a magic trick what the
wands look like like all these things
have to be created in your mind so when
i'm looking at the directors and i'm
like if they created all these things
like that all just came from their
imagination yes she described it in the
books but how it looks like in real life
i'm like you're a [ __ ] genius
like there's you're dealing with
make-believe so now there's no precedent
for make-believe you're right i'll walk
that back it wasn't maybe i'm getting
too excited no no no it was impressive
and i think he was probably the best
director like in this i don't know if
there's in the book or not there's so
many details it's hard to keep up but uh
like the way the staircase moves as
you're walking up and connects it that's
like a [ __ ] if you just imagine
that's like what a magical thing would
be that's dope as [ __ ] so he should be
in it but without her my interest drops
considerably and i think it's such a
[ __ ] move to not have her in yeah i
think you also uh as a creator have a
lot of respect for creators absolutely
and i think that there's certain people
that
they look at this as like a a parallel
universe to the one that they lived in
their life and they just want to see
these characters hang out together it'd
be almost like
if we saw like uh will smith and uh
charles charlton or whatever his name is
yeah
carlton carl
pharaoh yeah
i grew up with the fresh prince i love
the fresh friends reunion right right
see these guys coming together i haven't
seen them and even if they're not in
character you just like you're just like
oh this is fire to see these people that
i grew up watching like hanging out and
telling stories about i think for a lot
of people that's what it was and you
have a different perspective because you
create yeah so if you were
excommunicated from your own creation
you bet what the [ __ ] is going on over
y'all really gonna go talk without me
and i remember earlier when i first said
hbo and [ __ ] uh mark was like what about
game of thrones if that game of thrones
reunion without
george rr martin would you watch it and
i was like i probably wouldn't i would
but yeah but here's the difference
we hadn't really heard of game of
thrones as a book series i don't think
any of us had then this tv series comes
along and that's how we heard of it
harry potter every human being on earth
had heard of and then they were like oh
they're gonna make a movie about this
book that everyone has read every child
on earth has read this book that has
access to it
so you're just turning that into a movie
i want to hear what she has to say
because she's the one that made this
[ __ ] fire game of thrones none of us
knew about the books none of us have
interest in the books even now and
that's the only reason we care about it
is the tv series so i want to hear what
they have to say more than the author
yeah no jk rowling is different i don't
think there's anybody who doesn't want
to hear from jk rowling i think we all
do but
that's why it was more of a problem to
me i completely get that but i i was
excited to hear what each director had
to say and like what their process was
i'm also just curious about like you
know making films so it's like
how do you hire somebody who's gonna
have that vision like like the one guy
who gave them homework alfonso coron
whatever like that like yeah he was like
these people are growing up now like
this is where they become go from kids
to like young adults so i need to make
sure their characters are prepared for
that and like hermione's
emma whatever watson she wrote like
11-page paper on it harry potter wrote a
few pages ron didn't do it yeah and then
director went to ron and goes uh why
didn't you do it and he goes yeah i
didn't think my character would do it
that's fire that's fine like a story
like that is so cool yeah and you're
gonna get that story from the people
that was working with the kids right
yeah yeah yeah anyway i don't know it
was cool like the other director i
forgot which one um when he was telling
the twins how to fight with each other
yeah like the twins they wouldn't fight
they're like brothers so it's like hey
we're just gonna mushroom he's like no i
want you to really get in there so he
got in he's like which one do you want
to fight and one like raises his hand
and they really start tussling so much
that they the body slammed him and he
cracked like three of his ribs the
director yeah
correct and if you notice that all the
directors not a single jew
you know harry potter's jewish right who
daniel radcliffe yes
really really yes mother's jewish dad
so the opposite of what you're gonna
have
wow
wow shots fired both okay killed me um
yeah i don't know i just thought it was
uh i just was i i think it's annoying to
see these like uh publications just say
[ __ ] for uh clicks and not be a
comedy podcast
uh and that's my only issue
right like if they were just like yo
we're a comedy podcast comedy week i'm
fine with it does anybody hate the
babylon b
right nobody hates it it's funny it's
satire it's [ __ ] they can just say
things that are untrue in a funny way
and people go they listen they watch
they share the stories it's fun we don't
care so if you're one of these news
organizations that you know that you're
already saying fake [ __ ] just join the
team yeah be like us say the [ __ ] it
might be right it might not be right but
as long as it's funny it goes
if cable news network was cable
entertainment network i have way less of
a problem but you know what it is it's
way easier to just lie about things that
have happened
yeah sorry like the barrier to entry for
somebody consuming your content if
you're telling them the truth and the
news
you don't even have to be interesting
you could be like here the here are the
facts to be like
show they're laughing at everything
because they're like oh they're coming
up with all this in the spot yeah yeah
yeah and the bar is higher with stand up
because it's like oh no i expect you to
be funny
you probably worked on this let's go
it's just the bar is way higher for
what's funny and what's not right yeah
for entertainment you got to look at
like news is like i just want to see
something and i want to die i just want
to know what the [ __ ] is going on in the
world yeah
and for us it's like
you're not coming to find out what's
going on i'm coming to be entertained
yes entertainment perspective
specifically we have the hardest job
okay we're the best you hear that war
veterans yeah yeah yeah what up people
you just watch a clip from our weekly
patreon episode you can support the
flagrancy you can support this
unapologetic
unfiltered uncensored content that we
drop weekly on our patreon at
patreon.com flagrant2 you want to go
join you should because it's a top 10
patreon in the [ __ ] world that's
right for a good reason go check out why
at patreon.com
two all right peace